they're shooting right now and there's  an officer down it's coming from the  right over there  our whole mission today was to move in  peace in the show that la can't be  unified and not to bash the police but  to come up here and get some dialogue  with some communication because we're  all angels like he said we're all from  Los Angeles we all represent the same  cause and we all want to go home to our  families we are really really destroying  humanity as individuals and if you would  like to take responsibility as I am and  the people are here are we're doing it  as a whole and if we don't stop then one  by one our lives will do undo it away  along with our families and our  children's I have no idea what this role  has come to when it comes to the people  that have our back there's no need  obviously